when you're hired as a cinematographer
how many times will you read the
screenplay
for the film you're going to work on
well as i say in my early career not
enough times you know
now um
the only time that you really get to
read a screenplay is the first time you
read it
um and i think that goes for being a
director or
um or you know helping somebody else
you only get one fresh read so you're
only
seeing the movie continuously once to be
surprised by anything that goes on so
that
initial time that you read the script is
the most important
and it should be without a break um
you should never i think my acting
teacher nina fosh told me that
whenever you get a script all the way
through if you don't have enough time
that you can
sit down and read the whole thing you
shouldn't start it so
so i think that's initially that the the
thing is that
after the third time that you read it
then now it's starting to become really
technical
because you're um you're starting to see
the script in terms of the schedule
in terms of the locations where you're
going to do it
so at some point the the
breakdown becomes the bible that you're
working off
more than the script so there's a
there's a
there's a flow into you know that
first fresh read uh which is what
which is the most important to uh
going into the schedule and and the
breakdown
and seeing what it's going to take to
physically get the production done
you know why did nina your acting
teacher recommend that you
if you're going to read the script you
do it in one full sitting that you don't
take breaks that you're not
sending an email texting
i think you know when you sit in a
cinema and you
you you watch the movie that's how
you're going to experience it
and very often if you stop in a script
and and you pick it up you'll say oh
there must have been a day break in
there and you say oh no the script
happens over 24 hours you know so
um you know i think it it messes with
your uh
sense of time that you're reading it and
it also takes away from the
you know the script is going to be
performed
in one hour and a half to our piece and
that's how you should experience it
and experience it the first time because
you're never going to get that first
read
ever again and that's why if i'm
if i'm writing something and i want to
get a reaction from somebody
i'll be very careful about who who i
show it to at what stage
so i might be i'm i might be getting
pretty close to something
and i've got to write a friend that
knows how to read
something in a rougher state and i might
show it to them but if i want to get the
i'll never be able to i i won't be able
to use him again
uh because next time he reads it he
won't be reading it for the first time
so he'll have a different react that
doesn't mean that the feedback won't be
useful
but it'll never be that first fresh read
which i think is so important you know
how many acting classes have you taken
um
i don't know i did i did a whole session
with nina fosh
um i've done some commercial acting
classes
um which were very interesting because
commercial storytelling is like you know
1.3 seconds is
the unit's the time that you're working
on a little particular
thing and the production value that you
can put into that very short amount of
time
it's a very very interesting discipline
and i think from there so i think
three or four different acting classes i
took some improv classes
and but i then i kind of went
into more i started uh directing
with more different people which uh
was i'm headed more there than i am to
acting so
you know and where was this the
they were um in a rehearsal studio
um above a bike shop on melrose avenue
in hollywood you know she had a nice
nice little class there you know
do you have an internal checklist when
you're
reading a script before a film as a
director
as a cinematographer as a
cinematographer um
no i try to read the script
without thinking about anything and just
experience the
experience of script now as i say in the
technical process
later on then then the stuff
but basically by that time i'm usually
working off the location list
and the and the uh and the breakdown
whether it's day or night and
and you know becomes a much more
technical process but when i first read
the script
i try to be the audience and just sit
back and enjoy it you know
so then are there certain things that
you know within each scene
[Music]
you have to sort of tick off in your own
mind
like a a checklist broken down to each
scene
once you've gotten through the actual
sitting down reading the script as like
the audience would experience it
now there's like a a list of
requirements for each scene
technically that you're checking them
out no no i don't really work that way
i'm you know i have to say that um
you know people draw storyboards they do
little diagrams of how they wanted to
you know they do little thumbnails
but the but until you get the actors
onto the set and they block the scene
because because it's
it's fine oh well in the storyboard
you're over here and you know
de niro is saying no i'm not standing
over here i'm gonna be right here you
know so um
so the blocking of the scene
is that to me is when the scene comes
alive and when my
work can really start because
without seeing where the actors are
going to be you know lighting is very
active specific you know you can light
generally but if you want to do
something
very moody and special you really need
to see where they're going to be working
and until you get onto that set and see
where that is
and that's not until the director first
puts a scene together you know and um
working with directors i would say
two-thirds of them don't know how
they're going to block it before they
get the actors
onto the set others have very specific
ideas well we're going to do it over
here and
you know but
[Music]
the blocking process is is where the
day's work begins for me
you know and um checklists not not
really that's
a little too mechanical i'm i you know
there are some
shoots that are so tight that i have to
order equipment that i need for that day
just specifically for that one shot and
you've got to do that but you know
it's you you if you're making a movie
you don't want to
say oh well we don't have any dolly
shots today so we're not going to rent a
dolly you know there are
some things that are going to be part of
your package and you're going to have
and they become the repertoire that you
use to be creative and spontaneous
um but then there are other times when
you know equipment is going to be so
expensive or the budget's so tight
you're going to have to say i'm going to
use this on this day and and then you
get very short specific about
what kind of equipment you're going to
use in a certain place and what kind of
lighting equipment you're going to use
in a certain place
so then how did storyboards weave their
way into
seeming like it's a normal part of
production
is it just for some people it's a
preference well
i think it helps
storyboards help
non-visual directors visualize what
they're going to do
but really the birth of storyboards and
their greatest use to me
is in visual effects sequences because
then you're dealing with a discipline
that's so specific to what's going to be
in that particular shot
and how the sequence is going to work
because there are so many
you know you you can't shoot visual
effects like documentary and
you know it has to be very specific
and at that
time storyboards become the tool
to do that now
when you do a special effects sequence
in a in a
medium to large budget movie now you
have a pre-vis department
and storyboards have become now fully
fully animated sequences that
are done ahead of time and then you're
then you're kind of like
executing a an engineered movie
in the uh in terms of um
in in terms of uh what you're going to
need to bring
to a particular frame and shoot it a
particular way to get the movie made you
know
so um a lot of directors
don't really like that process because
their their freedom of
blocking a scene kind of goes away so um
i'm glad to say that in visual effects
now there are a lot of tools that are
being developed from like virtual camera
systems which are
putting that creativity back in the
director's hands
about being able to be much more
spontaneous about
how things are going to be done i saw
something about rogue one
recently their animated battle sequence
is were actually
shot by the director with a handheld
virtual camera
so he was able to uh
use that to be very creative and
spontaneous
about the way he covered like a fully
animated battle sequence
do you remember where you were when you
learned of stanley kubrick's passing and
how did it make you look at
the life of a career well it was kind of
full circle with stanley because
i hadn't seen doug trumbull for
many years and i happened to be
working in his
studio in the berkshires
the day that i heard that stanley died
and i was working on a very kind of
high-tech virtual
set that combined puppetry with
cg images so that the puppets were shot
with a virtual camera
and the wherever the camera was was
driving a computer which showed you
where you were in this
three-dimensional reality so it was a
brand new technology
that doug had kind of pioneered
and i was up there seeing him and we
both got the news together so
it was very sad so doug then left and
went to the funeral but
i was on this job so i was not able to
do the same thing
so sure did it make you look at
all great careers have some pushback or
you know like you can't be an
auteur without having extreme criticism
in one direction or the other that
that's part of the journey that's going
to happen oh yes i think so that
goes so much with the territory of being
an artist you know
is it they're going to be the haters and
they're going to be the lovers you know
so
um but i i had wondered at the time
because it was so close to the
end of uh i'd wise shut
that i didn't know whether he'd actually
finish the picture or not because it
hadn't been released yet
when he died and it wasn't going to be
for a little while so i i wondered
whether he had actually finished the
film but
uh i i believe he had and maybe
that was the sense of completion that he
did which would
would have been a lot better than uh
dying in the middle of a project anyway
so
that was yeah i felt good i felt good i
felt
a life well lived you know
you